and former Speaker of the House the one
and only N inrage N I want to take that
political question to you as well if
you're Joe Biden and you're constantly
at odds with Senator Joe Biden who once
said Sanctuary cities shouldn't be able
to do what they do employers should be
punished for hiring quote illegals he
said uh he wanted to make sure that
drugs pouring in from quote corrupt
Mexico couldn't get here I mean
President Biden is constantly at odds
with Senator Biden Senator Biden had a
point think he was more center right in
his views on immigration and border
security but as the as the problem has
increased in severity Joe Biden's
engagement on it has decreased and I'm
asking you first as somebody who's known
and work with Joe Biden for years what
you make of all that one two what about
the political currency that he's fing
away the polls show that immigration
along with inflation are his worst
handled
issues well look I think you can't
understand and Joe Biden without looking
at his eight years as Barack Obama's
vice president Obama is arguably the
most radical person ever to be president
protected by the news media when you
look at his underlying values and his
speeches and his policies and the people
he brought in he is extraordinarily
radical uh in that process Biden over an
8year period became sort of a uh mini
Barack if you will and so what you have
is we don't have a problem on the border
we have a Biden immigration
policy which is working perfectly if
you're a hardle person uh it's it's
destroying American identity it's
crippling the rule of law it is flooding
the country with people who haven't been
trained into the culture don't
necessarily understand how to function
in our society and create all sorts of
problems and I think we don't realize
yet this is a deliberate policy by
people who want to undermine America
change it profoundly and eliminate all
of those crazy ideas like the
Constitution the rule of law the work
ethic
meritocracy actually being able to know
and do something if you're on the hard
left those are all terrible ideas and so
what you have with Biden uh is a
commitment now I think politically
probably
it's going to be a disaster but they
don't see it that way they won the
presidency in 2020 uh they survived 2022
they had an okay
2023 I think they think that they have a
reasonable chance of survival uh and
they know that if they were to go to the
policies you and I believe in that their
entire left would erupt and there'd be a
civil war in the Democratic party so
Biden goes along with the most active
aggressive and militant parts of his
Coalition and what we have is what you
showed tonight on
television no new you're I don't know if
it's a full Civil War in the Democratic
party but you do see some people pulling
away from Biden on this you have the
Democratic governor of Arizona all of a
sudden finding religion on border
security John fedman the senator from
Pennsylvania and a few others and I
think they're reading the polls in the
te leaves they're seeing that the
growing number of Democrats and
certainly the vast majority of
Independents now put border security top
of the list and so I I think people look
at as National Security sovereignty as
well but as Stephen Miller was stating
there are things an ex Administration
can do when you were speaker of the
thinking back to your time as Speaker of
the House and as a congressional expert
what can the Congress do to support the
next president United States so that
everything's not through executive
action what should Congress
do well let me start with right now they
don't have to wait for next the next
president true I think that uh speaker
Mike Johnson has done a very good job of
setting it up to say look you want aid
for Ukraine you want aid for Israel fine
we're going to fix the Border here is a
Republican bill that passed that would
dramatically change the border and what
you've seen so far is the Biden
Administration and the Senate Democrats
have said no no keeping the Border open
having a few million more illegal
immigrants is more important to us than
getting Aid to Israel or Aid to Ukraine
and and I hope that the House
Republicans will stick very firmly in
favor of a policy which by the way at
America's new majority project we just
did a poll and 75% of the country favors
more border guards uh something like 67%
of the country uh favors the bill that
the Republicans passed in the house
there is zero opportunity to ever get a
majority in favor of Biden's illegal
immigration policy so if House
Republicans will stand firm you might be
shocked by January February March to
suddenly see the president have to
actually sign a bill uh that gets us
back to a trump policy which we know
worked I mean this is a matter of
practical fact the Trump policy on the
border worked we are a safer country we
had less ilal immigration we had a much
greater opportunity to grow and be safe
we stopped a lot of drug
a lot of human trafficking and a lot of
cartel activity we can get back to that
and the House Republicans under speaker
Johnson have taken a very important
first step in that direction Mr speaker
thank you for your wisdom and your
strategic counsel Merry Christmas to
kalista in you thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else